mark hamill pays tribute to his late  Star Wars co-star Carrie Fisher at the  2017 Tony Awards I'm here to rescue you  I've got your r2 unit I'm here with Ben  Kenobi  then kenobi wear it come on  mark honored Kerry on stage at the Tony  Sunday night as he presented the in  memoriam tribute this past year we lost  many beloved members of our theatrical  family legends of the stage artists from  behind the scenes princes of show  business and a princess Carrie died at  60 in December after going into cardiac  arrest on a plane  et spoke with Mark in April at the Star  Wars Celebration in Orlando where he  reflected on the actresses life and  legacy if she were here today the room  would be 10 percent funnier and that's  the thing I look forward to as the  premieres or whatever it was even when I  wasn't working with her I was in her  trailer hanging out because that's where  the fun ones  [Music]